その後アンミねやっぱりこう目とかあんな綺麗なあんな素敵な目なのにただでたいそれなのにお化粧してねもっとあの綺麗に綺麗にもっとなろうと思ったのかさでミキに怒られちゃったのまだダメだってまだお化粧なんかしたいって普段はいけませんとか言われて
しなくたってあんなに綺麗なんだからそうやね若いけどね
ハニカだからさすごくかわいいのよ
リキもよ本当かっこいいからね
リキももう何年も会ってないね
リキも今3人の一番性が高いのちょっとだけどね
リキも一生懸命勉強しててすごく大変なねあのなんかなんかなんか中の大学って大変なのね
ステイツユニラシティっていうのはちょっとそこへ入っちゃったんですよ
入ったんですよ入ったすごいな
いくつも多かった
アミって同じところも多かったんだけどね
でも結局そのステイツの方に入っちゃったから大変なの
下昇も高いしちょっと今ちょっと大変なの
でも一生懸命勉強してて随分できる
あの今全然困ってないみたいな
最初はなんかあの宿題とかね
最近は何だかわからないぐらいだって言ってたの
今もう全然なのよ
最近だけお家に今帰ってるでしょ
話した電話で
うんそうそう昨日
この間ね帰ってきたのよね
昨日
ああそうかいいな
今
うん
冬休み
でもそれないといけんとこでいいの?
もうちょっと寮じゃなきゃいけないのよアメリカ大学って
そうなの?
うん大体のところがそうなの
うん
アミもよ
そう
だからミキちゃん一人だからね
だから私2ヶ月もいたんだけど
うん
お前だろう
でもミキも忙しくって
私はいつも俺その
俺その番ばっかりなのって
ミキミキさんも全然いないんだもんってね
うん
ミキは何でしょうし
もうアミたられることしてるの?
なんか商売も始めちゃったし
うん
すごいね
キリコさんとかに
タカゴさんか
たかこさんに使われてるのよね、なんだかね。